hi everyone thanks for joining we're
going to get started now we have dr
moore here today so i'll turn it over to
him for some brief remarks
good afternoon bon appetit
on tuesday we further reopen the
province by lifting all remaining indoor
capacity limits for public settings and
removing proof of vaccination
requirements
we were able to do so because of
continued improvements in key public
health indicators though we are
monitoring some regional variation
particularly in the north
maldive
la provence
capacity atlanta
public
positivity is stable and new admissions
to hospital and icu have been declining
we recently saw a 25 decline week over
week for new covid admissions into
hospital
the unvaccinated continue to make up the
majority of covet 19 cases in intensive
care
these individuals have much higher rates
of immunization of hospitalization ico
admission and death compared to those
fully vaccinated and boosted
we're also seeing continued decreases in
the number of outbreaks in high-risk
settings such as hospitals and long-term
care homes we are paying close attention
to our wastewater surveillance which has
emerged as a key indicator to track
transmission levels in communities
most sampling sites in the province are
still showing a downward or stable trend
in covid
detections
but we have
been closely monitoring regions of the
province where there have been early
indicators of increasing trends
we will closely monitor for any new
variants internationally and are
tracking the presence of the growth of
omicron subvariant ba2 in the province
while ba2 is very similar to ba1
uh omicron subvariant that is currently
dominant in ontario we know that it is
30 percent more transmissible and will
likely become the sub variant in the
coming weeks
although we have listed lifted most
public health measures masking
requirements remain in place for now
bianca la marite de missour de sante
public
obligatory
museum
presents
protective measures are also in place
including requirements for indoor spaces
to post signage at entryways reminding
individuals to not enter if they have
symptoms or if they should be
self-isolating and requirements for
workplace safety plans
these additional health and safety
measures remain in place as added layers
of protection to help reduce the risk of
covit 19 transmission
as you know directives and letters of
instruction have been put in place for
multiple sectors
there's tremendous work and cooperation
happening across government as we
finalize the plans to transition to more
operation
with guidance and recommendations
that work is well underway and the final
stage is as we
look forward to sharing a path uh
forward
we are also fortunate that our
vaccination rollout continues to be
strong currently
90.6 of ontarians over 12 years of age
are vaccinated with two doses of a covet
19 vaccine
and 92.6 percent have one dose
we've also administered three or seven
million third doses this is an amazing
effort that is protected ontarians
through the brunt of the omicron wave
and a reminder that three doses can
provide up to 95 percent protection
against severe outcomes
we will also soon have another tool to
fight covet 19 in our vaccine toolbox in
late march the novovax vaccine will be
available through public health units
what
19 vaccine is the first covet 19
recombinant protein subunit vaccine
authorized in canada
this means it's the same type of vaccine
product that we we have used for decades
in our regular immunization schedules
for diseases like hepatitis
and pertussis
novovax is a two-dose series that can be
used also as a booster
we will have more detail regarding
supply and access in the coming weeks
the canadian vaccine medicago will also
has also recently been authorized by
health canada and we hope to have more
information to share about that vaccine
soon
having additional vaccine products at
our disposal will only help to increase
our immunization rates helping to
further protect ontarians from covet
19.
[Music]
la papa
we continue
our plan to reopen the province because
of the positive trends we are seeing the
result of the hard work of ontarians to
get vaccinated and to follow public
health measures in place
as part of our constant review of the
data
and
it all remains stable or improving we'll
be looking at removing remaining
measures
as we lift requirements
i thank you and i'm happy to take
questions
dr moore of course the big question in
many people's mind is uh the mandatory
masking policy um there have been a lot
of suggestions from the premier the
health minister that sometime around
march break is when we could see them
lifted can you provide us any further
clarity on the exact date that they
could be removed
we don't have an exact date date yet
colin but thanks very much for the
question so we've just reopened
yesterday
and all of those large venues can now um
be at full capacity we'll be monitoring
the data in the coming weeks i do agree
uh with the premiere and the minister um
that because the trends look so good
that we can anticipate uh
if the trends continue removing
mandatory masking
by the end of march
by the end of march
okay um one of the things we're noticing
is that the positivity rate is still
rather high believe it's somewhere in
the neighborhood of 10 percent or so and
you're saying that ba2 is now 30 more
transmissible than omercron itself
um what is that going to do do you think
to
um you know the the case counts in this
province i mean it's is it spreading at
large really undetected at this point
well thanks very much colin i
do want to ensure that ontarians are
aware the risk remains we are removing
measures over time
and that is because we have hospital
capacity we have capacity to care for
ontarians if necessary we have icu
capacity and we made the sacrifices in
january to protect to protect that
capacity to care for ontarians
we are removing measures because of the
high vaccination rate uh
and seven we should celebrate seven
million ontarians uh have now got their
third dose uh around ninety percent uh
over twelve years of age have had at
least two doses and because of that we
can open up safely that does not mean
that the virus isn't going to try to
continue to circulate and there will be
an ongoing risk in the coming weeks and
months of this virus continuing to want
to find those that are vulnerable those
that there's immunity is fading and or
that are immune suppressed so
together we will
confront that challenge of the risk of
ongoing transmission and and you're
absolutely right colin we're seeing it
in the percent positivity we're seeing
it in the sewage uh
positivity across ontario the risk
remains but it's at a much lower rate i
do believe the highest risk is behind us
we saw the risk of hospitalization peak
at around the third week of january
and we've had declining rates from 4000
down to about 800 ontarians in hospital
now testing positive with covet 19 but
it does not mean the risk is gone and
hence the reason we're keeping masking
and delaying removing that at a
population level for the next couple of
weeks as we follow the data
last week you said almost in the same
breath that masks are highly effective
at preventing transmission but also that
we'll be getting rid of them soon um so
why the discrepancy if they're so
effective what is the rush to get rid of
them well there's no rush because we are
following the data
and monitoring the situation very
closely so
we would anticipate as i've said by the
end of march we'll have a declining risk
and after that time period it will not
be mandatory but i ask all ontarians if
you're vulnerable to this virus if you
haven't received your full dose of
vaccine as a first second third or
fourth dose that you remain
prudent
that we remain kind and considerate to
those that decide to wear masks i know
this is a change for all of us as we've
been having that same messaging i do
believe they are protective they do
decrease your personal risk uh but the
uh
as the chief medical officer of health
we can only mandate masking for so long
as long as the risk is decreasing we'll
make a decision together as a province
to remove them but for those that are at
high risk for this virus i would suggest
you continue
to wear them and that as a society we
remain considerate kind respectful to
those that decide to continue to wear
them
as change management can be uh difficult
through
any pandemic the removal of masks i'm
sure will bring
just
make some feel ill at ease but also um
will
allow others the freedom to not wear who
who may have already had covid and or
have had their second doses their doses
uh and feel confident that they will not
require hospitalization if they get ill
you've also said that you wanted to lift
some of the workplace vaccination policy
mandates like the directives for health
care education um where are you at on
that are those going to be lifting
sooner or they going to remain in place
for a while longer so we have reviewed
our directives and we've reviewed
the letters of instruction that we put
in place so as of march 1st we've
reviewed we have removed two letters of
instruction which were to have
immunization policies for the ontario
public service as well as the second was
for our colleges and universities
uh i can say with great satisfaction
that the colleges and universities had
achieved in the high 90
rate of immunization of both their
students and their staff and have to
thank them
for implementing policies even before
there was letter of instruction to
provide the greatest level of safety for
their environment
they've served their purpose
and
letters of instruction have to be
removed over time because they're part
of the reopening of ontario act
and we're reviewing all of them
in the coming weeks and have a are
building a schedule to remove them in
partnership
with the organizations that are affected
doctor why are you still seeing increase
in the wastewater indications you were
saying this last week as well you were
talking about some areas of northern
toronto and northern ontario has
anything changed are there any new areas
is that ba2 do you know
ah so thank you so much so
a great resource for us is the science
table website
and they have broken
the
sewage down to regions of ontario so
you'll see if you go there today
increasing counts
across the in northeastern ontario
as well you'll see
it's not finalized yet but indicators
that
the rates had stabilized and they're
just slowly going up in many regions
across ontario and that's to be
understood we opened on the 17th more
fully at 100 capacity and now on march
first for the large venues at 100
capacity that we'd have ongoing risk of
transmission at a community level uh and
so i think we'll see that
most likely stabilize given the high
level of protection of immunization and
and
dr juni had intimated to me earlier that
it's the science tables belief that 30
to 40 percent of ontarians have had
natural exposure to the virus and hence
natural immunity uh and and
some of that
data is reflective uh of the ongoing um
uh detection uh in our in our sewage
systems
we
anticipate ba2 is taking over as a
dominant strain uh
in the omicron group of ba1 two and
three uh and that is happening
internationally as well uh given that it
has an in a competitive advantage it's
more transmissible than it's ba1 and we
anticipate it being the dominant strain
across ontario by mid-march
i don't want to raise concern because
we're not seeing any any increased
hospitalization from this
we do believe the vaccine provides a
very strong benefit uh
in in preventing hospitalizations and
severe outcomes um against ba2
but that is what our surveillance is uh
demonstrating at present
is there any chance that could change
in terms of uh
with the reopening you know when we've
got people
all jammed in at scotiabank center for
example at a leafs game
ah well it's a really good question that
we
because of our high immunization levels
uh and seven million ontarians who are
are higher risks so 86 percent of our
over 70s have had their third doses
i don't anticipate that will have
negative consequences from increased
exposure to ba2 like increased
hospitalizations i do believe due to the
robust immunization strategy we have
and the natural exposure that's already
occurred so 30 to 40 percent on of
ontarians have had exposure to uh kovid
uh that that combination of
of natural immunity plus vaccine
immunity is building a strong wall of
defense for ontario
against ba2 and potentially a recurrence
of delta um so that's good news from our
vantage point that uh again enabling us
to safely open uh in a staged and phased
manner in ontario
does ba-2 make you any sicker than
regular omicron or is it about the same
really good question we're we're not
seeing any increased risk of
hospitalization um
the only concern is that
transmissibility factor
so it can spread quite quickly and there
are some studies that show a very small
risk section if you've had ba1 you can
get a risk of reinfection with the ba2
variant but that seems to be a very
small proportion of all the
[Music]
testing
cases
recognizing that rapid tests yes are
more available now for ontarians but we
know they're not as good as pcr testing
is the province going to open it back up
again ever to the general public well i
think you you're the multi-prong
strategy that we have in ontario so we
still have a very robust pcr capacity uh
we're testing roughly 20 000 ontarians
on a daily basis
and
have been
distributing around 5 million rapid
antigen tests weekly across ontario and
that combination i i think is
being able to provide ontarians with the
testing capacity that we need
we still need to keep a rapid turnaround
time for our pcr and i'm happy to say
within two days we're getting in the mid
90s of results back for those high risk
settings uh hospitalized patients as
those as well as those in long-term care
in retirement homes so our current
strategy is working very very well
um we always want to know that the
sensitivity specificity how well that
rapid antigen test works against omicron
uh in that it's still an effective test
to be used uh and we're monitoring um
and we'll make recommendations if we
think that the um
we need to
change back to increasing dependence on
on pcr but at present i think we have to
recognize we've had a really robust uh
testing strategy
with the incorporation of the rits
why not open it up i mean if the lab
system isn't totally swamped right now i
recognize yes you want to prioritize for
the higher risk groups
but i'm assuming that volume has come
down as well
and even if you could explain this sort
of a side question he said you'd think
30 to 40 percent of ontarians have had
exposure to copenhagen how would we know
that given that many many ontarians
especially in the last few months
haven't been able to get a pcr test oh
so
specifically
so they're they're a great question uh
the the way we know that is we do
ongoing uh seroprevalence studies and
and so for example you would donate
blood uh at a
for the canadian blood transfusion
service
anonymous testing of that blood can show
if you've got antibodies against natural
infection or antibodies that have been
induced by vaccination and there's a
difference in those antibodies
and when we do several prevalent studies
across canada we're seeing the level of
protection against and natural immunity
is building in an ongoing way and there
are also research groups across canada
i think quebec announced that they're
very confident that children in quebec
in montreal in particular had around 35
percent natural exposure to kovic those
research groups are across canada uh and
that has allowed the science table to
provide that information to us an
estimation of 30 to 40 percent of all
ontarians have had natural exposure but
on the testing front
it's working well for us right now
we have good availability of rits we've
got good turnaround time with pcr
and it there will come a time when um
the incidence rate is so low
that if you have a positive rat test
done at home we will test you get a
confirmatory pcr so we're
we're keeping that spare capacity
for the time when um due to the low
incidence which could happen
we would recommend a confirmatory test
through pcr okay so just to clarify
that's not the current situation but
hinting suggesting that will change yeah
um again i guess
if you get around take a rapid test you
get your hands on one and it's negative
it doesn't mean you don't have code
that's correct
so
why not let people go into an assessment
center and get a pcr test so
it's not well it was it was the capacity
that we wanted to maintain initially for
the pcr uh and the in the turnaround
time to allow us because the turnaround
time was getting to three four days so
it wasn't actionable for outbreak
management within long-term care sectors
so we're constantly getting feedback
from the expert panel on testing of when
we need confirmatory of rat testings
with pcr we're not there yet but we may
get there in the coming weeks or months
that we'd need confirmatory
right now a positive rat in the
community absolutely should be
acceptable as a positive test two
negatives 24 hours apart is better
suggestion that you do not have covet
19.
if you have ongoing symptoms you should
still stay home there are other viruses
circulating
in ontario right now rhinoviruses
adenoviruses enteroviruses are still
circulating right now and can cause very
similar symptoms
and we'll go to the phone lines for the
last question
from cynthia mulligan at city news
hello dr moore um back to the wastewater
for a moment
you've suggested that in some areas
they're showing an increase and i know
that's not unexpected
but do you have a sense of what the
actual numbers are we know that we had
roughly 2 200 cases confirmed today
uh what would the actual number be does
the wastewater give you any sense of
that
well it's a good question for the uh the
modeling group um
in
my recent discussions
with them have been that we could do a
multiplication of around 10 times the
pcr positivity so if we're seeing 2 000
positive tests 2262
at a population estimate we could be
estimating around 20 000 ontarians have
uh coveted 19
today as we speak
and um that is building the combination
of vaccine immunity and community
immunity that we need to be able to slow
this virus down
last question okay i think a lot of
people would be quite shocked to hear
that number
the other when we get to masking
i know in alberta premier kenny is is
moving to prevent municipalities from
imposing their own separate public
health restrictions would you recommend
the same here for example if toronto
felt there was a concerning rise in
cases
would they still be allowed to impose a
mass mandate even if it has been lifted
across the province
well really good discussion point we
have great relationships with our local
public health agencies uh our regional
associate chiefs are meeting with them
on a regular basis we've had regional
approaches across ontario and that has
worked for us so we're in ongoing
dialogue with all 34 regions of ontario
at times we've all had different
approaches because of varying levels of
activity
and we've been consulted at a local at a
central level to be able to provide that
consultation locally so that dialogue's
been ongoing it's been well received and
we have in ontario had regional
approaches i don't think that approach
will change uh and should celebrate you
know our local public health agencies
work
hand in glove with their local municipal
government so
whether you put a recommendation in
through a bylaw or a public health
section order
we we would be ready for consultation
and support uh if there was a need
thanks everyone
good question